[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend im deutschen grundgesetz
steht ein ganz wesentlicher grundsatz
nicht ausdrücklich drin gilt aber
trotzdem der sagt das parlament darf
sich nicht drücken nicht den
wesentlichen dingen wenn es zum beispiel
um menschenwürde und das recht auf leben
geht da müssen sich die abgeordneten des
bundestages und die länder im bundesrat
den problemen stellen und entscheidungen
treffen
an diesen grundsatz erinnert das
bundesverfassungsgericht heute in einem
wuchtigen urteil wenn es dazu kommen
sollte dass die möglichkeiten der
krankenhäuser in deutschland nicht mehr
für alle patienten reichen dann darf der
gesetzgeber nicht sagen ihr mediziner
macht das schon er muss per gesetz einen
rahmen setzen für solche entscheidungen
das hat er bisher nicht getan einen
rahmen der dem grundgesetz genügt und
nicht zb blind den fittesten patienten
einen vorsprung gibt es waren körperlich
behinderte menschen die ihr recht auf
leben gefährdet sahen und sie haben
heute recht bekommen die abgeordneten
haben eine schwere aufgabe bekommen
sarah tacke und sarah kirsch bericht mir
wurde relativ schnell von ärzten gesagt
dass ich wahrscheinlich mehr gut
infektion nicht überleben würde einfach
frei nicht nur sehr eingeschränkt
atemmuskulatur
nancy poser ist hochrisikopatienten
sollte sie sich mit corona infizieren
sie müsste sehr wahrscheinlich auf eine
intensivstation
dort fürchtet sie wegen ihrer
behinderung nicht behandelt zu werden
weil ärzte ihre überlebenschancen als zu
gering einschätzen könnten deshalb hat
sie geklagt und heute gewonnen erreicht
dass es eine gesetzliche regelung geben
muss die sie die menschen mit
behinderung schützt
[Musik]
grundlage des urteils ist artikel 3
grundgesetz
niemand darf wegen seiner behinderung
benachteiligt
werden doch die richterin richter des
verfassungsgerichts hier bei beratungen
karlsruhe sind das für den fall der
trias nicht sichergestellt sie fordern
dass der gesetzgeber unverzüglich
schutzmaßnahmen für menschen mit
behinderung erlässt denn aktuell
orientieren sich ärzte an empfehlung von
fachgesellschaften danach ist einzig die
überlebens chance ausschlaggebend
geschaut wird wie ist der aktuelle
gesundheitszustand wie gebrechlich ist
der patient und hat er schwere
vorerkrankungen durch die seine chance
zu überleben gemindert ist bei dieser
aktuellen vorgehensweise sei nicht
ausgeschlossen dass ärzte bei einer
behinderung pauschal von schlechteren
genesungs aussichten ausgehen meinen die
richter dass sie den gesetzgeber in die
pflicht nehmen freut auch mediziner die
sich mit der schwierigen frage oft
allein gelassen fühlen ich habe mit
einer ganzen reihe von kollegen
gesprochen alle wünschen sich dass die
verfassungsorgane
leitplanken vorgeben dass es belastbare
regeln gibt von daher ist das gutes
urteil aber auch eine schwierige aufgabe
für die verantwortlichen politiker die
haben sich heute nur über den
kurznachrichtendienst twitter geäußert
hier schreibt der bundesjustizminister
marco buschmann das erste ziel muss sein
dass es erst gar nicht zur trias kommt
wenn aber doch dann bedarf es klarer
regeln die menschen mit handicap schutz
vor diskriminierung bieten die
bundesregierung wird dazu zügig ein
entwurf vorliegen wie der aussieht da
gibt das verfassungsgericht dem
gesetzgeber einen großen spielraum aber
auch deutliche hinweise darauf wie ein
gesetz dafür sorgen kann dass ärzte auch
in extremsituationen
diskriminierungsfrei entscheiden indem
zum beispiel ein mehr augen prinzip
vorgeschrieben wird verpflichtend ist
dass ärzte immer kollegen hinzuziehen
müssen wenn sie über leben und tod
entscheiden oder das verpflichtende
weiterbildungsmaßnahmen vorgeschrieben
werden klägerin nancy poser hofft dass
das neue gesetz breit diskutiert wird
und so rechtssicherheit und
rechtsklarheit für ärzte und patienten
schafft
der chefarzt professor uwe janssen
dieses mitglied im präsidium der
deutschen vereinigung für intensiv und
notfallmedizin und hat mitgeschrieben an
den richtlinien die für dort zurzeit
geltenden guten abend nach aachen
ja ich grüße sie herr kleber nahm wird
sich durch das urteil des
verfassungsgerichtes möglicherweise
etwas ändern in den richtlinien aber
auch in der praxis die sie seit jahren
ausüben
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt werden wir das
noch mal sehr genau überprüfen das
schriftstück das
bundesverfassungsgericht aber sehen zum
heutigen tage noch keinen anlass an
unseren empfehlungen die wir übrigens
gerade im dezember noch mal neu
formuliert haben und upgedatet haben
hier eine änderung vorzunehmen an
unserer praxis im alltag ändert sich
jetzt der zeit gar nichts denn wir
erfreulicherweise haben wir dieses
horrorszenario der priorisierung der
triage wie das bundesverfassungsgericht
das ja apostrophiert hat haben wir
derzeit nicht und hoffen auch dass
obwohl die omikron variante jetzt droht
dass das nicht auf uns zukommt und
eintritt nun sind solche richtlinien und
entsprechend dann was dann kommt das
gesetz ja ausgerichtet dafür da solche
fälle vorab zu regeln bevor es zu spät
ist und die hektik der krise alles
überwältigt und da scheint mir aus der
begründung des urteils so ein stück
misstrauen mitzuschwingen das in der
praxis der intensivstation vielleicht
dann doch mal der fittere den vorteil
bekommt gegenüber zum beispiel einem
behinderten menschen
ja das haben wir auch so wahrgenommen
und wir müssen das zunächst mal so hin
den bedauern das sehr weil wir
eigentlich von anfang an denen unser
leitungen das ziel gehabt haben hier
genau das zu verändern wir haben genau
unser leid dahingehend ausgerichtet dass
dieser umstand halt nicht berücksichtigt
werden soll das in priorisierung
entscheidung herr kleber halt zum
beispiel behinderungen nicht einfluss
nimmt und davon völlig unabhängig
entscheidung getroffen werden wie
übrigens auch das alter oder soziale
umstände geschlecht und hautfarbe
keinerlei rolle spielen und im übrigen
auch nicht der impfstatus nun kann es ja
vorkommen dass ein mensch durch eine
behinderung zum beispiel ein stark
eingeschränktes atem vermögen hat einen
verengten brustkorb zum beispiel und
eine erkrankung wie corona die dann auf
die lungen geht da hat er deutlich
geringere chancen das zu überleben als
ein patient der voll fit als sportler
durchtrainiert auf der intensiv nation
liegt können sie dann als arzt wenn sie
nur einem von beiden helfen können
wirklich sagen wir richten uns nach
diesem gesichtspunkt überhaupt nicht
nein wir würden uns nach dem aktuellen
krankheitszustand beider patientinnen
halt richten wir uns sehr genau
beurteilen wie die eine patientin mit
der schweren angeborenen störung der
lunge und der andere patient ich gleich
an der erworbenen störung der lunge
jetzt umgeht angesichts seiner schweren
kopf 19 moni und dann fließen hat viele
andere faktoren ein wie reagiert der
kreislauf die übrigen organe kommen dass
da ein multi organ versagen und da
kristallisieren sich dann bei den
patienten schon unterschied daraus aber
das kriterium der behinderung spielt für
uns definitiv an der stelle kein
entscheidungskriterium das können wir
als ärztinnen und ärzte in deutschland
wirklich versichern und dazu stehen wir
auch nun ist es indirekt aber dann doch
ein faktor weil die behinderung neben
den medizinischen zustand des einen
patienten möglicherweise so
verschlechtert dass es am ende dann doch
die entscheidung gegen ihn oder sie
ausgeht
schauen sie mal wir haben so viele
patienten kleber die auch nicht
behinderungsgrad haben die schwer
erkrankt sind chronisch seit jahren an
zuckerkrankheit übergewicht
bluthochdruck herz kreislauf krankheiten
line und herzschwäche auch diese
patienten haben einen gewissen grad der
behinderung die sie mitbringen und zwar
zum teil sehr ausgeprägt so schauen wir
gar nicht auf diesen faktor sondern
schauen tatsächlich auf das was bringt
der patient an reserven mit in die
intensivmedizin und sind die reserve des
körpers des körpers den er mitbringt
ausreichend dass er die schwere akute
erkrankung übersteht und da er
kristallisieren sich tatsächlich bei dem
einen und den anderen patienten
unterschiedliche ausgänge heraus und
darum geht es doch um nicht darauf zu
schauen wie jemand mit welchem status
und welchem grad er und ob er behindert
war oder nicht hier auf unserer
intensivstation behandelt wird und das
ist uns wirklich wichtig und dazu stehen
wir auch und sind auch tatsächlich ein
bisschen traurig gewesen dass trotz
aller diskussionen in den letzten zwei
jahren mit den behindertenverbänden hier
ist so weit gekommen ist dass diese
entscheidung getroffen ist wurde da sind
wir auch froh drum denn wir hoffen uns
dadurch auch rechtssicherheit für uns
ärztinnen und ärzte imtech jungen mit
solchen schwierigen entscheidungen die
ansicht des erfahrenen intensivmediziner
uwe janssens herzlichen dank dafür und
einen guten abend noch nach
ich danke ihnen herr kleber
das gespräch haben wir aus technischen
gründen schon vor einer stunde geführt
auch in russland hat das oberste gericht
heute eine entscheidung gefällt sie
bedeutet das ende dort der
renommiertesten menschenrechts
organisationen des landes und passt
perfekt in eine politik der harten hand
aus putins kreml die systematisch jede
quelle von kritik an seinem regime zum
schweigen bringt sogar unsere
korrespondentin in moskau berichtet
elena katyn nova kommt oft zu dem
gedenkstein am einstigen hauptquartier
von stalins geheimpolizei wo heute der
inlandsgeheimdienst fsb seinen sitz hat
auch heute abend erinnert sie sich an
das schicksal ihres volkes der
russischen minderheit der cham ecken und
an ihre familie zurück video 1943 wurden
die keine mücken innerhalb eines tages
zusammengetrieben und in güterwaggons
verladen sie wurden auf alle regionen
sibiriens verteilt meine großmutter neun
kinder auf dem weg verloren sie wusste
nicht einmal wo man sie beerdigt hat
es ist der verdienst von memorial dass
die nachfahren des stalinistischen
terrors gedenkstätten haben dass die
lebensgeschichten der millionen
todesopfer nicht vergessen sind heute
wurde das gewissen russlands wie einige
die menschenrechtsorganisation nennen
aufgelöst nach gerade mal drei
verhandlungstagen
schande rufen die prozessbeobachter die
das urteil als politisch motiviert sehen
boka sowie heute hat sich klar und
deutlich gezeigt dass russland kein
rechtsstaat ist und dass es in zukunft
nur noch schlimmer werden wird das recht
existiert in diesem land nicht mehr
der russische staat und hier vor allem
einer reißt die deutungshoheit über die
geschichte an sich über den sieg der
sowjet armee im zweiten weltkrieg
erklärt der präsident nur stock unsere
pflicht ist uns immer daran zu erinnern
welchen preis dieser sieg gekostet hat
und wir erlauben niemandem diese
heroische seite unserer geschichte durch
zu streichen wir werden jedem versuch
entgegen treten die geschichte zu
verfälschen
das historische heldentum erhält unter
putin verfassungsrang stalins diktatur
wird verklärt seine verbrechen am
eigenen volk erklärt als notwendigkeit
um für ordnung zu sorgen
massen erschießungen vertreibungen
russlands führung distanziert sich nicht
etwa davon sondern bestraft diejenigen
die daran erinnern
russland verwandelt sich von dem
autoritären putin system song in einer
art post modernen totalitäres
indem es eine verbindung geben wird zu
dem sowjetregime
teilweise sogar zu dem stalin regime
am ende eines jahres in dem russlands
opposition
reihenweise hinter gitter kam in dem
jeder protest niedergeschlagen wurde
setzt die auflösung von memorial einen
schlusspunkt der viele erschüttert wenn
wir die schreckliche vergangenheit
vergessen die memorial untersuchte so
wird dieser schrecken zur gegenwart und
zukunft unseres staates
wie viele befürchtet sie dass der
heutige richterspruch alle hoffnungen
auf ein freieres demokratischeres
russland beendet
manche fachleute glauben dass putins
hartes auftreten vor allem dazu dienen
soll das er auf der weltbühne vor allem
schere macht zelt wieder auf gleicher
augenhöhe wahrgenommen wird nachrichten
passen dazu von gundel ag
vertreter russlands und der usa wollen
am 10 januar über den ukraine konflikt
beraten beide seiten bestätigten dass in
genf geplante treffen dabei soll es um
eine entschärfung der situation an der
grenze zur ukraine gehen russland soll
dort seit wochen zehntausende soldaten
zusammengezogen haben der russische
präsident putin hat bei einem
gipfeltreffen ex sowjetischer
staatschefs
sicherheitsgarantien vom westen
eingefordert er erneuerte seine mahnung
die nato müsse ihre ost erweiterung
stoppen 30 jahre nach dem ende der
sowjetunion war putin für eine weitere
zusammenarbeit der früheren
sowjetrepubliken die bundesregierung
kauft eine million packungen des corona
medikaments packs sowie der us firma
kaiser
gesundheitsminister lauterbach erklärte
er rechne mit ersten lieferungen im
januar das medikament sei extrem
vielversprechend früh verabreicht könne
die tablette einen schweren cupid
verlauf deutlich abschwächen
erneut ist es in manchen städten bei
sogenannten corona spaziergängen zu
rangeleien zwischen demonstranten und
der polizei gekommen dabei sind im
sächsischen bautzen einsatzkräfte mit
feuerwerkskörpern attackiert worden
zwölf beamte wurden verletzt
auch in mannheim widersetzten sich
demonstrierende bei einer nicht
angemeldeten versammlung der polizei
gleichzeitig erinnerten hunderte
gegendemonstranten mit einer
menschenkette an die toten der pandemie
im
hafen der syrischen stadt latakia hat es
mehrere explosionen und brände gegeben
syrische staatsmedien zufolge soll das
feuer durch einen israelischen
luftangriff entfacht worden sein
berichte über verletzte oder tote gibt
es bislang nicht das israelische militär
äußerte sich nicht zu den vorwürfen
latakia ist der bedeutendste
handelshafen syriens
der bürgerkrieg in syrien ist nicht
vorbei geht weiter mit seinen
unberechenbaren parteien innen und von
außen mit seinen unübersichtlichen
zickzack frontlinien und wechselnden
machtzentren verschlingt er meist
unbeachtet von mess lich medien jeden
tag menschen lieben russland die türkei
iran haben dort weiterhin ihre hände im
spiel und auch die usa mit einer kleinen
truppe von etwa 900 special forces ihr
auftrag die türkei draußen und die
terror miliz es unter druck halten das
ist kein krieg von armeen und
feldschlachten drohnen einsätze sind
dort die waffen der wahl der tod soll
sozusagen einzeln kommen zur ces
kämpfern von besonderem wert high value
target ausgesucht von geheimdiensten die
eiskalt auch den materialaufwand einer
tötung in rechnung stellen das ist ein
krieg der aus der ferne geführt wird wie
ein web-basiertes computerspiel
entscheidungen fallen in der wüste von
nevada 10 zeitzonen vom ziel entfernt
über eine relaisstation im deutschen
ramstein
meist bleibt das alles verborgen in
einem fall unserem fall nicht daran
hassanzadeh und anrufe können mit
unserem eigenen material das schicksal
einer ganz harmlosen syrischen familie
belegen den einer dieser angeblichen
präzisions angriffe nahe kam furchtbar
sie haben überlebt erst die angriffe auf
ihr dorf dann die flucht vor syriens
machthaber assad und jetzt einen
drohnenangriff auf offener landstraße
der einem al qaida kämpfer galt die
familie fuhr im auto dahinter zu den
großeltern die caps eine einfache
bauernfamilie sie sind das was die armee
einen kollateralschaden nennt die kinder
saßen auf dem rücksitz
der in der kreide
meine ganze familie wurde verletzt mein
sohn und ich wir sind so schwer
getroffen und wir haben kein auto mehr
uns ist nichts geblieben
mutter fatima müsste wieder ins
krankenhaus doch sehr panische angst vor
der fahrt aber die entzündung bekommen
sie hier nicht in den griff
ich weiß nicht wie ich meine gefühle
beschreiben soll ich sehe den schmerz
meiner frau mein sohn meine töchter
mahmud beine und der kopf ich habe seit
vier tagen nichts mehr gegessen
der ort al rawi hier leben die
großeltern die gegend ist auch ein
rückzugsgebiet für al qaida kämpfer am
dritten dezember ist die familie auf dem
heimweg fröhlich film die kinder der
motorradfahrer im blauen anorak ist das
ziel des drohnenangriffs gleich wird am
anderen ende der welt ein us-soldat den
knopf drücken es ist der moment in dem
sich vater ahmed entschließt zu
überholen
[Musik]
es gleicht einem wunder dass der
zehnjährige mahmud überlebt er wurde im
35 kilometer entfernten idlib
notoperiert danach lag er drei tage lang
im koma ihm fehlt ein teil des
schädelknochens
tage später kehrt vater ahmad an die
abschussstelle
zurückfindet teile seines autos
wir haben saft getrunken wir waren
glücklich auf dem weg nach hause die
kinder hatten spaß
mit einem schlag verwandelte sich dieses
familienglück in ein blutbad schreie wir
haben alle geschrieben ich tat was ich
konnte dann kam rettung daran erinnere
ich mich dass da habe ich getrunken
das ende eines familienausflugs mehr als
300 drohnen einsätze hat die globale
allianz gegen terror im norden syrien
dieses jahr geflogen
dieser wurde gefilmt und
das pentagon hat bestätigt dass das ein
eigener angriff war
zurück nach deutschland und zu themen
der wirtschaft
an den finanzmärkten legten die kurse
weltweit zu der dax kletterte wieder
richtung der marke 616 1000 punkte und
immer wieder denken anleger investoren
und analysten über eine mögliche
konsolidierung eine kurskorrektur nach
valerie haller wie wird das an der
frankfurter börse diskutiert kontrovers
wird das diskutiert weil viele risiken
auf den tisch liegen und so die prognose
diesmal enorm erschweren die mehrheit
schaut aber mit gedämpften optimismus
auf die nächsten wochen und monate viele
erwarten steigende kurse aber eben nicht
mehr ganz so große sprünge wie noch in
den vergangenen monaten wenn auch es ein
recht erfreuliches jahr für anleger war
16 prozent plus der dax trotz der krise
man merkt aber der winter den börsen ist
rauer geworden die schwankungen stärker
das zeigt anleger sind nervös weil es
eben viele risiken gibt mögliche neue
virusvarianten der weltweite liefer stau
und die inflation um nur einige zu
nennen und manchem wird die rasante kurs
jagd langsam unheimlich denn einige
aktien sind inzwischen teurer geworden
sehr teuer besonders die tech-werte die
dieses jahr gigantische kursgewinne
gemacht haben wie die aktien von tesla
microsoft und die dem google mutter bett
selbst die aufseher der europäischen
zentralbank warnen schon vor renditejagd
und zu hohen bewertungen an den
aktienmärkten und vorkursen die sich von
wirtschaftlichen fundamentaldaten
abgekoppelt hätten der hinweis und
dieser stelle ist insofern bemerkenswert
da die notenbanken mit ihrer
niedrigzinspolitik die kursrallye erst
so richtig befeuert haben und am 20
januar tag der ezb-rat wieder wir
berichten danke valerie
ein wintersturm hat im westen der usa zu
stromausfällen und verkehrschaos geführt
aufgrund der ungewöhnlich heftigen
schneefälle mussten hunderte flugzeuge
am boden bleiben auch im norden von
kalifornien und nevada fiel so viel
schnee wie nach angaben von
wissenschaftlern seit über 50 jahren
nicht mehr die us behörden warnen vor
einer längeren kälteperioden dort und
weiteren heftigen schneefällen
große überraschung im ski alpin beim
weltcup der herren in bormio hat sich
der deutsche dominik schwaiger den
fünften platz und damit ein ticket für
olympia gesichert auf der besonders
anspruchsvollen stelvio piste in
südtirol kam er mit einem 1,1 sekunden
rückstand auf den erstplatzierten
dominik paris ins ziel der italiener
gewann zum sechsten mal in folge auch
ein neuer rekord nach der weltcup
abfahrt steht nun das super g rennen an
morgen beginnt in oberstdorf die 70
vierschanzentournee und die
skispringerinnen können sich hoffnungen
machen dass es das traditionsevent auch
bald für sie gibt der präsident der
tournee erklärte die vier
austragungsorte seien sich da einig für
das auftaktspringen morgen haben sich
sechs deutsche skispringer qualifiziert
mit einem flug auf 127 funktions meter
landete lokalmatador karl geiger in
oberstdorf auf platz zwei der
qualifikation auf platz 1 der japanische
mit favorit review kobayashi
nach einem jahr erzwungener pandemie
pause hat die europäische union wieder
kulturhauptstädte europas erkoren es
geht längst nicht mehr nur um die
sowieso schon weltberühmten touristen
magneten an denen europa so reich ist
sondern immer wieder um verborgene
perlen an denen europa noch reicher ist
2022 leuchte die aufmerksamkeit auf eine
perle im baltikum die auszeichnung soll
kaunas der vergessenheit entreißen eine
stadt die vor 100 jahren ein gefeiertes
beispiel der moderne war und auch eine
zeitlang hauptstadt das wird nicht
zurückkommen die ehre bleibt bei vilnius
aber anziehend ist kaunas auch wenn man
genauer hinschaut wie anne brühl
manchmal erschließt sich die schönheit
nicht gleich auf den ersten blick kaunas
an der memel im grauen winter ist so ein
fall die stadt ist voller
modernistischer bauwerke ein zufall der
geschichte denn zwischen 1920 und 1940
war kaunas mal hauptstadt von litauen da
wurde gebaut was das zeug hielt
in diesen 20 jahren haben die litauer
ungefähr 6.000 gebäude errichtet
wunderschöne häuser die zwanziger und
dreißiger jahre waren ja die zeit von
artdeco modernismus bauhaus ein modernes
und anbau hause
karolis besitzt ein eigenes kleines
museum ein appartement im ursprünglichen
zustand das er liebevoll ausstattet
alles soll so aussehen wie 1929
architektur kunst ausstellungen theater
für das kulturhauptstadtjahr hat sich
kaunas viel vorgenommen auch große namen
wie yoko ono oder robert wilson werden
vertreten sein
wir zählen auf 4.000 künstler die im
nächsten jahr im programm dabei sein
werden das ist da so eine riesige
kreative energie in der stadt und ich
hoffe das ist dann nicht nur so für ein
jahr sondern auch für viele kommende
jahre
aber auch die traumata des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in kaunas noch spürbar so
wie derzeit deutsche besatzung und
holocaust themen die die kulturmacher
nicht aussparen wollen
wir wollen darüber reden was als
nächstes kommt wir wollen aus der
geschichte lernen um es zu akzeptieren
und gemeinsam darüber sprechen welche
zukunft wir wollen dass
die eu an
modernes tanztheater auch das wird es in
kaunas 20 22 geben im stück das sie hier
proben geht es um klassenunterschiede
die jungen tänzer kommen aus der ganzen
welt julia ist litauerin und findet dass
das eigentlich keine rolle mehr spielt
ich würde sagen kaunas und littau und
kommen richtung europa nach westen und
der westen kommt aber auch richtung
osten so würde ich das sagen das ist ein
treffpunkt und die geografie spielt doch
gar nicht mehr so eine große rolle
bei der großen eröffnungsfeier ist doch
julia mit dabei der tanz der bauwerke
wird dann auf die entsprechenden häuser
projiziert dennoch nicht sind sie in
kaunas so stolz wie auf ihrer
architektur
zieht aus über uns und das haben wir uns
zurzeit keine hochhäuser verfügbar dafür
aber die welt im blick morgen abend
wieder zur gewohnten zeit sind wir
wieder hier um 0.30 meldet sich nah
sagte mir mit unserem heute-journal
update
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter auf dem atlantik dominiert tiefer
luftdruck oder auf der vorderseite
dieses umfangreichen tiefs kommt warme
luft zu uns und auch regenwolken sind
mit dabei und die ziehen weiter ostwärts
im osten deutschlands war nach nordosten
ist es noch gefroren und so wird es in
der nacht teils gefrierenden regen geben
hier also müssen sie mit glatteis
rechnen
der kann durchaus gefährlich sein und
bis in die vormittagsstunden
anhalten ansonsten ist vor gibt es von
frost keine spur des dominieren die
wolken es regnet und im süden weht ein
kräftiger westwind nach norden hin
bildet sich nebel teilweise lockert es
sogar auf und die temperaturen sinken
auf minus 1 grad im nordosten
deutschlands und 9 grad im südwesten
morgen gibt es viele wolken die durch
ziehen immer wieder regen kann auch
kräftiger sein vor allem nach süden
zwischendurch ist es aber trocken auch
nach osten bleibt es zunächst mal
trocken bei höchsten temperaturen von
zwei grad an der ostsee oder mildesten
wird es nach westen vor allem im
südwesten mit 14 grad 16 grad mild wird
es dann am donnerstag oder zu viele
wolken mit regen ganz im nordosten ist
es noch kühl um die 7 grad ja und am
silvestertag wird es relativ freundlich
seien nach süden im norden ziehen viele
wolken mit regen durch und vor allem
richtung nordsee gibt es auch viel wind
teils stürmisch und damit wünsche ich
ihnen einen schönen abend